Monsters University quiconque descend
Je suis officiellement un étudiant
J'ai attendu ça toute ma vie
mec
je ne peux pas être en retard le premier jour sans
ski room 319
tu sais que ton colocataire est un
major effrayant - ok viens ici mec wow c'était
génial
James P Sullivan Mike Wazowski eh bien maintenant
qu'on nous a présenté tu ne penses pas
J'ai peur que tu ne sois même pas dans la
même ligue que moi tes mains sont aussi
grosses que mon visage c'est fou
Rhonda je suis désolé je vais effrayer les cercles
autour de toi cette année tu dois te
moquer de moi
aah Oh effrayant je suppose  Je serai juste là
pour écouter ma musique
oui je reçois un bol d'araignées correct Je
vais essuyer le sol avec ce petit
je-sais-tout la
peur est la vraie mesure d'un
monstre n'y va pas c'est dangereux Oh qu'est-ce que
tu es  faire là-haut, je ne peux pas retourner
en prison,
battre la ceinture d'accord, quelqu'un veut juste
il est comme une montagne avec de la fourrure je ne
m'entraîne même pas ouais moi non plus
je ne veux pas devenir trop grand